here's the story and it's it's actually
really simple
quote some cities may run dry for a few
days a few days I wonder what that means
for you how do you feel about not having
gas for your truck for a few days that
sound fun diesel supplier warns
businesses on the east coast to prepare
for diesel shortage after Russia cut off
Imports the other day on the show people
were super chatting that the supply was
down to like 20 or 19 days it's still
down it's it's not improving they are
resupplying but not as fast as we are
consuming so it is getting a little bit
worrisome that our diesel supplies are
the lowest point since like 2008. have
you guys I just want to point this out
too diesel supplies are at the lowest
since 2008 like more housing prices
mortgage rates interest rates like all
of these things are starting to we keep
hearing like inflation is worse since
two as bad as it's been since 2008 you
know they keep they keep saying that and
you guys remember what happened then
right in 2008 yeah yeah we almost
completely toppled the economy almost
that we uh we taxed everyone I don't
know 10 I think over the course of 20
years they're going to pay out 20
trillion or something to pay off those
Banks from 2008 I don't know the exact
numbers they say businesses which rely
on the fuel have been told to take steps
to plan for the potential lack of Supply
which is mostly caused by Russia cutting
off Imports this means that businesses
are not receiving the high number of
petroleum products they were before the
invasion of Ukraine the diesel shortage
is also caused by high distillate demand
refinery maintenance and lower Refinery
capacity
you know it's it's a scary story but
let's be real Democrats all have Teslas
so this isn't going to bother them at
all right I mean Buddha judge it was him
right he told everyone to buy Tesla well
there you go problem solved Democrats
don't have to worry about it midterm
yeah AOC has one she's probably really
happy now and what was that
congresswoman that said that when gas
prices were high she was driving by her
with her Tesla and and celebrating that
she didn't need to pay like the other
peasants what was her name I forgot oh
yeah
I don't know but come on look come on
are you so so so they're saying because
of the diesel shortages you're gonna
you're gonna experience a couple
different things potentially there may
be some you know cities running dry in a
certain sense but they're going to
prioritize this by having higher prices
so they may bring in fuel from other
areas to supplement those that are
running low and try and make sure
there's kind of like a triage going on
so ultimately the most likely scenario
is just higher gas prices it's not the
end of the world and besides if you're
really concerned about five dollar
gallon gases buy a Tesla it's only sixty
thousand dollars so you know problems
solved right there on the low end 160
000 if you want the high end but you
know and that's reasonable for the
average American you know just to spend
160 Grand on a car might as well before
inflation makes it you know not valuable
anything you know what's that remember
that Dan Aykroyd I think it was Dan
Aykroyd joke it's SNL he's like
inflation's great don't you want to
smoke hundred dollar cigars wear a five
thousand dollar suit drive a ten
thousand dollar or what do you say like
thirty thousand dollar car or something
it was the 70s but but also just to
continue this story on there's a lot of
other problems ahead of us particularly
because we're just entering right now
the high demand season for diesel and a
lot of people use it for heat and so far
we had a mild fall we're entering into a
mild winter but but if winter gets
severe a lot of people are going to be
using diesel needing it to heat their
homes uh a lot of the country a lot of
the trucks a lot of the farming a lot of
the infrastructure is run on diesel so
with the refineries and imports slowing
down and the demand increasing yes the
price is going to go up dramatic
medically from here and hopefully we
could avoid an utter tragedy from
unfolding here but this is uh this
year's problem it's expected to get
worse the second year the third year as
of course this is something that isn't
going to be fixed anytime soon as the
conflict between Russia and the West has
of course been escalating and with those
escalations there are consequences this
is one of them a diesel shortage we had
a super chat before the show started so
I just want to let everybody know if you
super chat before we go live YouTube
erases those super chats but it was from
someone named D lamb who mentioned that
the person who delivers like I guess
heating oil was that what it was he said
they can't guarantee the supply over the
winter yeah in the UK we heard the exact
same thing the BBC is secretly preparing
messages for when there's energy
shortages like blackouts or something
and they're saying they that there may
be rationing or shortages of fuel for
heating people's homes in the winter uh
mind you they said at the beginning of
December not only even to the Christmas
holiday so December yeah yeah you can
get well uh like upside down Planters
pots those clay pots and then you cut a
little hole in the top and you put
candles inside of them they create like
heat yeah like holds the Heat and then
makes like a like a little bit of you
know radiator and then you put like
layers of them so you put a larger
planter on top of a smaller planter and
you can get a lot of ambient heat for if
you don't have heat and also I don't
know how important it is but don't they
use diesel to transport diesel yeah yeah
yeah it's a compounding compounding
problem and gasoline and and basically
everything so if there's a shortage of
diesel it means you might not have
eggnog or sour cream or whatever it is
you're trying to get for the Christmas
holidays well isn't that convenient
though I mean because we're saving the
world right now so you mentioned the
candle in the pot and stuff I mean
that's just good for the environment
anyway yeah you know I mean this is what
it's all about we should be figuring
isn't that convenient right how to
survive next you know what we should do
let's start let's let's look up how to
catch rabbit and then and then I learned
this I think it uh uh who told us this
when you're eating rabbit you got to
make sure you crack the bones and and
get the fat out of the marrow because
you know otherwise it's called rabbit
starvation they don't have enough fat in
them so you can't just eat rabbit but
with the bone marrow you should be good
fat numb it sounded like an element
a large segment of the world Heats their
homes with kerosene right now and it
causes massive like uh lung problems
because they're breathing in the black
smoke so I think candles might on a you
know if you if you scale it up cause
something like problem like that you
don't want to breathe in Candle smoke
um especially though people resorting to
kerosene it could be a big big problem
you gotta make sure things are
especially scented candles you don't
want those extra scents you know that
yeah bug anus yeah it's one of my
favorites I've been thinking about the
policies of Joe Biden the administration
Democrats and you know what's the what's
all the fuss about I'm not poor it's the
poor people who have to suffer under
Democrats and they voted for him so you
know I I advocated to help you know
people but uh they they get to root what
they sow and then we can all uh um you
know sit back and and sit atop our
balconies drinking fine wine in the
Ivory Tower right Luke's down for that I
don't know about that that's not really
true but you know I have a better idea
why don't we just try surf them I think
that's going to really help the planet
and you know we might as well just serve
the monarchy and the ruling Elites and
just base our lives on providing for
them you know I think that's a really
nice idea good point though but think
about this right what's going to happen
to your average company when the economy
completely collapses the I mean the
people are gonna have no choice but to
become serfs right like if you own the
company you basically become an oligarch
you know so the economy collapses
there's no resources and then all of the
all the working pores come to you and
say please help us and then you go oh
the pause want my food and uh you know
as long as you're hanging out Democrats
they got a plan for this I'd imagine
because they're the ones who made this
all possible I love that the the pores
has made its way back into the cultural
conversation yeah Elon Musk is going to
give the Poor's access to verification
oh yeah well I thought we were in a um
in a uh transition because didn't Biden
say that like the the gas shortage was
part of the transition at some point
like a few months ago yeah so so is it
on purpose is it like not on purpose I
don't know to get serious with it and
you know I I just
I can't believe people voted for this
and there's a certain point where I
understand the people who are watching
and listening to the show like this you
didn't vote for it you voted against it
you voted to protect yourselves you
voted for protecting the lives of your
family your friends and making the world
better and then the Democrat voters who
voted in the Biden Administration other
Democrats voted on hatred with no real
plan a man who's not all there and it's
just making everything substantially
worse and the scary thing is they're
going to vote for fetterman they're
going to vote for more of these
Democrats despite I mean this is
fascinating I was reading this article
on why we're going to see this Red Wave
even in New York where the safe Democrat
areas are almost flipping Republican now
and they said I think it was an it was
time I'm sorry was it New York Times
sang
you have Democrats right now campaigning
on abortion and Maga when crime is up
like 40 and gas prices are through the
roof and Republicans are campaigning on
these issues like we're gonna get your
gas prices down and deal with crime and
the Democrats just say but don't you
want to abort your kids and the people
are like I don't care I'm hungry dude I
need to drive my car so now all of a
sudden in New York there's one poll
showing Lee zeldin is beating hokel
Republic we could have Republican
Governor so you're saying the country is
not going to be voting for The Biden
administration's policies because they
support Dylan Mulvaney you say Dylan
mavini is not as popular to Galvanize
the American public to make them support
this Administration and the amazing work
they're doing in society while
destroying everything else uh again it's
absolutely crazy what's happening here
and another aspect that we should really
try to understand here is that the gas
prices right now the diesel prices right
now are at a price with the government
doing a lot of things behind the scenes
artificially trying to keep those prices
down just a couple of days ago just a
couple weeks ago Biden went to Saudi
Arabia and literally begged the Empire
to produce more oil up until the midterm
elections Saudi Arabia said nope we're
not going to be doing that we're
actually going to tell everyone your
plan and screw you over as you're
pushing for of course a Green Revolution
that will essentially screw over Saudi
Arabia in the long term but but again
what else is the government doing right
now to keep these prices low what are
they going to be doing after the
election when they don't care that's
going to be another big impact factor
here when it comes to the price of gas
and Diesel going up I gotta say you know
uh we're we're one week away from the
actual midterm election day votes are
already coming in we just had the
libertarian candidate endorse the
Republican in Arizona for Senate which
is crazy Masters and I kind of feel like
whatever you think about 2018 and 2020
with the Democrats winning you can only
fool the people for so long when you try
to crank up gas prices take away energy
production generally make things worse
because you have some weird cult
ideology about the world ending
eventually a regular person says you
know I'm done I don't care I just want
you to guess
so they can do whatever they want they
can say whatever they want they can play
whatever dirty games they can Riot they
can scream and eventually someone just
says I can't pay gas I'm voting for the
other guy
we'll see we'll see you know you don't
want to count your chickens before they
hatch but uh
even Joe Rogan said the Red Wave that's
coming is going to look like the
elevator doors opening and The Shining
it's going to just flood through and
there are some projections this it may
be substantially worse than even the
projections are making it out because
right what's happening is Real Clear
Politics 538 they're tracking all these
polls and they're like look at this
Republicans are up one point that
predicts we're going to see you know
this many seats in Congress then you
factor in that the pole stars are all
completely wrong and they're off by like
7 to 13 points and it there's there's
some scenarios 53 is presented where
Republicans can have like 260 seats in
the house just absolutely 56 seats in
the Senate
I don't know about all that but you tell
me that Diesel's running out and I'd say
okay you give me the day before the
election gas at five bucks a gallon and
everyone is just being like no no don't
care Republican just whoever is not in
charge right now yeah it's funny because
Biden said just the other day that
that's how much gas was when he took
office he couldn't even remember that
gas was actually half that price when he
took office so or he's lying or he's
lying or he just yeah or he's often
Never Never Land but I think that people
are getting pushed to that point now
where they've they voted just because
they were sort of conditioned for four
or five years to take whoever it was
going to be on the other side and now
they're sort of facing the backlash of
that where you you can't afford food and
gas the two you know or a roof over your
head for crying out loud so yeah I mean
I don't know what they're thinking we
saw what happened in France when they
added that tax on petrol which increased
the price by only like a dime or
something it was two years of Rights
basically they have to understand that
if they want to carry through their
weird climate change agenda great reset
whatever you want to call it
you put people homeless in the streets
and we're seeing more and more homeless
people this is probably why eventually
you have just disorder and Chaos are
they are they hoping for this do they
think that Civilization is going to pull
through and people don't have a place to
live and they're starving now those
people are going to get mad they're
going to smash windows and take stuff I
guess that's what they want how do you
how do you look at those cities and vote
for more of it the conditions of it
right now the last time I was in San
Francisco you could smell the urine in
the air and it's gotten worse since I
mean New York's not too dissimilar New
York what sour milk like you walk
through Midtown and just you get a whiff
of siren up periodically and roasted
nuts and roasted nuts that's true too it
smells fantastic if you're lucky yeah if
you're lucky but it's like giving it's
back and forth sometimes you're in
depending on where you are but now we've
got all the crazy Subway crime you see
this stuff in New York City where people
are getting pushed in front of trains
some dude got stabbed kids are getting
robbed and uh
the Democrats are campaigning on
abortion I feel like cleaning the Earth
is something that we do when we're
stabilized like if we're at war or in a
state of chaos we're just going to
produce be doing what we need to do to
survive and producing waste as the
byproduct until we find a place of peace
and stability where we can go back and
clean up all the waste like waste
management is very low on the real life
living survival priority thing so if for
to cut out people's fuel supply and then
expect us to like peacefully transition
into a state of like green energy is not
it doesn't logically transmute for me
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a mass
library to check out so again go to
timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there